this new story i love um ross take this
one away okay well
our next guest was born with cerebral
palsy and he wanted to go away to
college without
having to worry about who would tie his
shoes so
he wrote a letter to nike yeah nike
asking them to design a shoe
that could be used by anyone and you
know what
nike responded and an innovative line
of hands-free sneakers was born so here
to tell us about it
the inspiration behind it all please
welcome matthew walter hi matthew
i drew high rolls oh my god this is
amazing i can't believe i'm here and i
just want to say
that you know i'm so grateful thank you
so much for
for allowing me to come on and share my
story
i think about you know i wrote i wrote
this letter when i was
when i was 16 when i was a boy in high
school
and now years later as a man i'm sitting
here on your show
still with the same story that's still
resounding and impacting people
you know almost 10 years later so so
it's incredible when you sat down to
write that letter
did you have a goal in mind or did you
just want to
get something started as i got to high
school and i'm thinking about my future
and
and going going to go away to college
and live on my own and
and be as independent as i could how was
i going to go away to school
if i can't tie my shoes and it's not
just me there are so many other people
out there
with physical challenges that struggle
with the same thing so i really
just i i put my heart and soul into this
letter
well and you put your heart and soul
also into the process i i hear that you
were
involved in the design process you
brought your nice experience to it tell
us a little bit about that
they wanted to know what my my needs
were as far as
uh cp and struggles that i faced so i
have full dexterity in my left hand
uh my right hand is pretty weak but
aside from that i
i don't have a lot of dorsiflexion and
plantar flexion in my foot so
i have a hard time getting my foot down
and into a shoe like making that motion
and so um they the first concept that
they
sent me at 17 was a modified basketball
shoe
um and for the first time in my life at
17
i put my own shoes on independently and
that moment for me
was something that i'll never forget you
know most people
we put our shoes on in you know early at
kindergarten early elementary school
but to do it at 17 when i was never sure
if that moment would ever come
was just um so impactful
so they would send me prototypes um and
i would we would
we would skype there was no there was no
zoom then and
i would give them feedback on all things
that are so
integral when you're talking about
universal design and
ease of use of a product especially
with footwear you're why i just want to
be here on this planet
you're the living example of like why
i'm not interested in going elsewhere i
want to
be here to experience the capacity of
what
humans can do with and for each other
yes i just oh i i am so
happy to be talking with you and meeting
with you
and um i'm happy drew i'm so happy
to to be here truly and and share my
story and
i want the i i've received so many
messages outpouring of thank yous over
the years but
something that sticks with me is a young
girl when i first wrote the letter
her mother wrote a blog on a parenting
website
and her daughter has cp and and she was
saying that you know reaching out to
nike with this letter is such an
important moment
because as parents we're concerned about
how
our daughter is going to put her shoes
on going forward she was two years old
at the time
and that to me was the moment that i
knew that
i had to to do this to advocate for
people
and my big resounding message here is
that for so long people with
disabilities have had to adapt
to the world everything around us we've
had to accept
what the what the world can give but now
in 2021 the world needs to do so much
more you know we're willing to to to
listen and work
with with people and companies and
organizations and our own government
to to have to make sure that our needs
are met you know there's so much talk
about
equality which is uh so important
but what people don't realize is that we
also need equity
we need equity we need we need to be
reassured that we
can have what we need as individuals to
succeed and live an independent
life free of free of barriers free of
obstacles
i wish i could build the world's biggest
platform for you to stand on
every day and remind us of how we're
supposed to be
in this world and um it's so it's so
important
and people a lot of people lose sight of
this and i just want to thank you for
not losing sight of
of what's of how important this is this
is about more than just shoes
it's about universal design not just in
products but in life it's making life
easier
because people don't understand the
struggles that we have to go through
as people with disabilities whether it's
it's shoes
or driving or education there's always
barriers there's always red tape
and i just want the world to know no
more no more red tape
please it's so important and then and
and nike is has has done amazing things
and now we need other
other companies and organizations and in
the world to
to step up
it's about messy it's about knowing what
it's like to walk in other people's
shoes
and i think you've been so articulate
here um
and really enlightens all of us so thank
you matthew thank you for that
and we would like to announce that the
cerebral palsy foundation
is honoring you with a 2021
national cerebral palsy awareness day
award
and this will be celebrated on march
25th and you'll join other honorees in
the health education and advocacy design
and technology field
and that again is just something that we
can share with you today
congratulations thank you thank you
it's incredible you're amazing and i
would love to
do more talk more speak more figure more
things out with you
and um thank you to the foundation for
allowing us
to be a part of that announcement today
it is humble for us to even get to be a
part of this moment thank you i'm so
honored thank you guys for making all
this possible
go to our website to learn more about
the cerebral palsy foundation
which will be honoring matthew and
rightfully so
[Music]
you